hi in this video I'll be talking about
the adherence Junction so in the
epithelial cells there could be multiple
different type of cell junctions there
could be adherence junctions there could
be gap junctions there will be tight
junctions and so on so in this
particular video will focus on adherence
Junction and its physiological relevance
and importance in development and cancer
so the adherence junction between two
cells are just like something is hooked
into into a wall so it's like so there
would be something anchoring region and
on the other hand side there should be
some support and we would be talking
about that in this whole video so here
are the two cell junctions in a
magnified version so you have the
Kandarian molecules in a second we will
talk about Kettering molecules in
details and you have the actin
microfilaments so the actin
microfilaments are the rigid supports
and caring is one side attached to the
actin microfilaments by several adapters
which are termed as ketamine's and on
the other hand side it is attached to
another Katerine molecule so there is a
homo philic interaction between two
katraine molecules from two sides of the
cell and each of the Caterine molecules
coming from the cells are connected to
the actin cytoskeleton from this of the
cells right now since one of the
connection between these Caterine is
very weak there are multiple different
connections between Catering's in array
so together all of these connections
make it a strong connection now these
can here in proteins are connected to
the actin cytoskeleton by cations one of
the important catenin is
for catenin beta-catenin and also be won
9-0 catenin so all these ketamine
molecules are working like a adapter
which is attaching the caffeine molecule
to the actin cytoskeleton cytoskeletal
but apart from its attachment function
or adapter function catenin molecule is
an important platform for for signaling
for example beta-catenin is important
for wind signaling so this could have
also signaling roles as well
now these Kettering has 5 accessory
lured domains which are like in a
jumbled situation when there is no
calcium available or with when the
calcium level is low part when the
calcium level is high there is a
conformation shift so it becomes more
rigid and less flexible and they also
diamond rise to form a rigid structure
which is like which can interact in
Catron molecules on the other hand side
and this homo philic interaction though
each homo physical interactions are weak
but together all the homo philic
interactions make it a very strong
junctions and connection between them
so kattiline basically connect to nearby
cells like a velcro so each of the
interaction between the velcro is weak
but together the velcro interaction is
pretty strong so this is a crystal
structure of the kattiline which shows
the ec1 domain of the caffeine from
coming from the each side of the cells
are interacting with each other and the
can't really need calcium for their
interaction so it has been seen when the
calcium is washed away or calcium is
chelated the a turns the in in vitro
situation or even in vivo situation the
Catering's cannot interact with each
other in a strong manner so there could
be multiple different type of adherence
Junction sometimes they are punctate so
they are known as punctate punctum
adherence sometimes they are like a zone
or band of a transaction known as dual
adherence and there could be been
complicated tri cellular adherence
Junction as well
so we now talk about adherence Junction
and it's important and kattiline it's
important in terms of the development so
we talked about the neural tube
development so we know after
gastrulation there are three defined
germ layer spectrum the mesoderm and
endoderm the ectoderm give rise to the
nervous system and the ectoderm is a
lipid Linea so the epithelial cells
Express ich adhering but the ectoderm
just top of the notochord starts
expressing in Kettering and otherwise
known as new rector term so you can
understand the new rec program is just
differentiated from the nearby ectoderm
by the expression of specific different
ket hearing in Kettering and the other
ectoderm tissue express ekaterina so
depending upon the expression of the
adherence Junction proteins the tissue
identity could be different now later on
when the neural tube is folding and
neural crest cells are migrating out
they express different type of ket
hearing for example the region which is
known as the floor plate which is just
about the notochord starts expressing
cat hair in 6p whereas the other cells
of the neural tube expressed different
care hearing different in capturing the
migrating cells which are neural crest
cells Express catcher in seven so
depending upon the type of Quechua you
need to use its adhesion properties are
very different and and sometimes the
duration remodeling can give rise to the
cell migration and cellular change in
cellular architecture now we talk about
brain development in the brain
development these adherence Junction
proteins especially the Catalans has
huge role now when our brain is
developing it has something called
ventricular zone in the ventricular zone
there are mostly cells which are
neuronal stem cells their progenitors
they would give rise to neuron and clear
eventually they are connected to each
other by these adherence Junction
proteins especially the cat hearing -
now what happens is
the the and these specific interaction
between the cat herons are very strong
they allow these cells to divide
continuously an increasing number before
they can give rise to other particular
other particular neuron or clear and
these advanced Junction based
interaction also ensures that they don't
heal the ventricular zone and miss
migrating to other regions so they
there's a whole steel on the top of the
ventricular zone so what happens is this
cat Halon - which is one of the specific
neuronal cat hearing is very important
in in some cases where this Katerine -
is mutated there is drastic changes in
the brain so in the normal mouse brain
it has been seen there are apical
progenitors marked here in cream and the
basal progenitors are marked here in the
red are distinct are separated by
distinct zone now what happens in a
kettle into mutant mouse is the apical
progenitor and the basal progenitors
their adherence properties are altered
so they kind of intermingle with each
other and they move out to any location
that leads to a huge defect in layer
formation in the brain and the whole
brain seems to be jumbled up the whole
cortex seems to be jumbled out and even
should be the animals type not only in
brain development or the relative
development in terms of cancer if we
think then here is a epithelial
carcinoma we are talking about and then
eventually the worst case scenario is
the cancer cells migrating to other
locations by a blood stream and they can
detach from the epithelia because their
adherence properties are now different
it turns out that most of the cases the
expression level of ekaterina in cancer
cells are drastically low than the
controls that allowed them to easily
detach from the epithelial layer and
move around the body and invade other
organ and thereby giving rise to a
secondary cancer outcomes so this
how adherance junction and cell
junctions plays a vital role in cellular
morphogenesis from brain development
human cancer if you liked this video
give it a quick thumbs up don't forget
to Like share and subscribe and do let
me know in the comment how do you like
my videos thank you